the legend trish stratus hey so good to
see you yeah I mean what's up what's
happening nothing right much is a little
wrestling match coming up yeah okay for
fans and and and et Canada viewers
explain how we got here today okay okay
the back story the last couple weeks
okay so here so I'm a retired wrestler
arguably it's been said people have
called me one of the the great ones of
my era absolutely I'm not saying it so
no you are you're an absolute legend in
the wrestling world it's been said and
so currently there's Charlotte Flair
daughter of Ric Flair yes she has the
pedigree of the lineage and she is I can
tell you she's an incredible athlete
incredible performer and she is number
one in the women's division right now
she is the number one female and the
idea came up SummerSlam is our second
biggest pay-per-view for WWE and it's a
huge one and it's in Toronto so there
was kind of some conversations about
like it has some Trish in there what I'm
gonna do and I'm at the cottage um well
and then this idea came up and we
thought is a pretty epic one you know
kind of like the it's just generation
force generation era had era and and to
find out who's the greatest female
superstar of all time well we already
now like I think I already know I mean I
already know we already know because
like we're pals
well it's true though I mean you don't
Canada's own after all that's right you
know but it's just it's a it's a crazy
scenario like just the fact that it's in
Toronto that it's part of SummerSlam
that she's at the point of her career
and I'm as well it's it's a really
interesting just on paper it's an
interesting dynamic just that that
offering and it's just been unfolding
now a weekly so now I know I appeared on
television she called me out there was
some some words said and it's been
really fun and she calls herself the
Queen and I've kind of said well if
you're the queen that I'm the queen of
Queens and it's just been in Twitter
Wars and it's been like there's been a
lot going on well the one thing though
Charlotte Flair your opponent at
SummerSlam said on Monday that she has
nine title reigns and seven and but I'm
not concerned at all but what's gonna
happen here are you I know so she's got
nine Tyra and I've got seven right right
so
was unprecedented for years I write the
seven-time Women's Champion and no one
could touch that and didn't touch that
yes I mean eyes are tired 2006 yes a
long time ago right and then she
suddenly came up and there are some
questions about her reins perhaps one of
her reigns was only five minutes okay it
still counts this time okay okay
what I might bring it up at some point
if I need to okay yeah but the
interesting thing about this match which
is what makes it really unique as
usually is about the championship and
that drive and that you know to be the
best in that division
we're not even it's not even a
championship match so it's not even
about and we've barely talked about the
titles maybe we did touch it on Twitter
a little because she was trying to do
this but I noticed it right back on
yes but it's it's a unique scenario
because you don't often get that where
this match sort of this of this
heightened awareness to have that with
no championship behind it is really cool
and to know that we have the interest
and it's not even a championship match
is is really unique it's incredible
now she kind of got you going with some
mommy shaming yeah tell me I mean I
think I know why but why did that fire
you up so much well okay here's the
thing that all moms can relate to is
sometimes you lose who you are yeah
right and you you're just your mom and
you're that when you're in the bun and
and you know sometimes when you're sure
when you come to work and you're like oh
I still got it can you forget when
you're near mommy why not before I can
write that came out really cute yes here
she is right but some moms don't have
that outlet to find her right and I
don't have a weekly television show so I
don't find her as much but you know I go
to my office like go pick up the kids I
do nothing and I do my work and of
course when I do my when I do my
signings or I speak engagements trish
stratus comes out and like there she is
but you forget who yeah so you know her
calling me out and sort of being in this
this arena and having the fans there and
being in that moment it was almost like
I had to think and dig deep and be like
am I crazy what am I even doing here
first of all like it's been eight years
since I've had a singles match I've had
two children since then as well it's not
like I trained at the you know the the
gym every day like the way I used to and
have that stamina that you know muscle
health I guess I mean come on you're
incredible yeah that's different I do
yoga like I do my yoga to me I like
basically do my yoga so that I can still
like move around young like a young
person with your kids and look the mir
and go look looks good yeah cool you
don't mean it's not about muscles and
building this and all this but so I feel
like I
had to dig deep to kind of find my inner
church Stratis if you will but I think
all of us as moms we do that we have to
find ourselves and then she's still in
there you just it's good and it's really
like it's important to tap into that
every once in a while
we're not fired you fired me up and and
it was funny cuz one week to the next it
was just like a whole other thing and
yeah it's been it's been fun it because
I feel like it's a little journey for me
to kind of get here as well and I kind
of feel like can I say bit bad you can
say whatever you want that I yeah you
can say I feel like about us like about
us mom and it's kind of cool right it's
kind of an interesting dynamic to have
that and it's been it's been good I feel
like you're doing it for all the moms
I'm doing it for the mom think you're
doing it for the moms too mom has to
find their inner about us I've noticed
that thing you know many wrestlers have
been coming back you know switch they
bring the men back quite a bit
yeah and now they brought a few of the
women back but not so much as the men do
you think that that's starting to shift
in that arena I think there was more men
available to bring back maybe that sort
of thing you know they definitely tap
into the nostalgia and there's just like
there's so many legends especially on
the men's side there's just so many that
just we had that raw reunion recently
and right all kinds of super stars were
coming back for that and Stone Cold
Steve Austin sort of led the charge with
that and it was just it's I think people
love that nostalgia specially rusty
bands they love seeing that like
old-school and absolutely it makes you
feel something yeah and the other thing
is when I do my autograph signings now
I'm signing for like a like a kid and
he's like the dad's there going I showed
him the best like I told and so he's now
teaching that to his kid and with our
network you know the you can go back and
watch anything and relive all the
moments and it's really cool to see how
it's like just being passive Agenor
ations and the women in your network are
having some really great moments I feel
like there's great storylines for women
that are very empowering for young girls
to see how important is that for you
watching that sort of evolution oh it's
it's honestly everything that we set out
to do in the beginning you know we like
you said we were sort of under the radar
and then all of a sudden the girls were
getting more opportunities and able to
show a different side of what a female
at least how the females presented in
the resting room well we're complicated
you've got storylines for days right
yeah I know but that's kind of cool
because I do tap into that as well yeah
so it's been yeah it's been really great
and and to see now like cut to come back
into the mix and seeing some of the
current crop of females and they're like
I watched your mash in 2004
mm-hmm and I wanted to be a wrestler and
it's like it's such a crazy thing to me
to hear that that this is like a
vocation now like little girls like I
want to be a wrestler when I grow up but
I'm 16 my months that I could go to
wrestling school and I'm like wow like
that's because people say did you want
to be a wrestler when you want when you
grew up no because there was no option
I knew Miss Elizabeth and she walked
them into the ring but I didn't know I
could actually get in now there's that
option we can get in and and have
matches and have interest just like the
men do and that is super super cool and
very empowering so does that mean we're
going to see much more of you in the
ring after Sunday Cheryl I feel like
this is my final bow because I feel like
oh I just feel like you can't get a more
epic moment of finality it's like my
fights whenever tired which retirement
is a loose term and wrestling it is sure
in any field yeah yeah yeah I'm sure if
you retired from here we see we see how
popular they're right yeah so in 2006
I've made my you know I was retired at
30 so there was still room for reduced
up I guess right so I came back pick my
spots and came back but you know at my
age and at my point in my life like I
don't know if there's another match
scenario that could be with the two
perfect
you know opponents where it's gonna be
in Toronto at SummerSlam it's just it's
too epic you know and I don't think I
could trump it and I feel like I would
just leave that moment alone you know
what I mean but you did say I don't know
if so there's like there's a small it
open a little size